hey there guys just a quickie today so a
lot of you have noticed that I've gotten
a bit leaner lately and I've had tons of
questions from people asking how that
happened and how they can get more
defined ABS well actually it happens
partly by accident it happened partly
because my wife and I started eating
dinner with our daughter as she's old
enough now that meant we started eating
more healthfully I decided I couldn't be
bothered with cooking additional courses
and sides for myself
lockdown also meant I couldn't grab
snacks whilst out and if we run out of
things like protein bars I had to wait
until the next weekly shop
and I kind of went with this because we
were in lockdown and that mean I didn't
have access to the heavy bench pressing
or squatting I was used to so it made
sense for me to focus a bit less on pure
strength and a bit more on calisthenics
and mobility things like that
calisthenics benefits from being a bit
lighter and yeah I enjoyed the way that
leaner physique felt so I leaned into it
and pretty much ate what my wife ate a
slim 5 foot 4 inch woman and added some
protein shake on top of that and that's
gonna do it in my video titled why you
aren't losing weight / building muscle I
described that calculating your active
metabolic rate is a very inefficient way
to work out your calorie burn this is
why counting calories doesn't work for
everyone
but it remains the best starting point
for most people so if you want to get
leaner just calculate your current
calorie burn the AMR and then aim to eat
around 200 to 500 calories less than
that per day you can find AMR
calculators online if you want an even
easier strategy and if your weight has
been roughly consistent over the last
few months
simply cut some big things out of your
regular diet no matter necessary if you
aren't gaining or losing weight it means
you're roughly eating your calorie
demand eat a bit less problem solved as
for where to lose those calories you'd
be surprised what cutting butter sugar a
bit of milk etc out of your diet can
achieve
likewise use less oil in your cooking
etc or use the strategy I outlined in my
book super functional training and eat
low calorie meals for breakfast and
lunch so that you can safely enjoy
yourself at dinner dinner tends to be
the most social meal and that means we
like to really enjoy it so this method
works really well for me the other key
to ripped abs though is to train your
core properly a lot of people will tell
you that getting great abs is only about
diet and this just isn't true while
losing fat will mean that your abs look
more visible through your midsection the
truth is that you also need to make them
stronger so that they push through more
don't believe me try contracting your
abs and looking in the mirror you'll see
that they look better that's because
you've flattened your stomach by
tightening your transverse abdominis and
protruded your six-pack by flexing your
rectus abdominis get stronger and your
abs will look closer to this all the
time this will also improve your posture
don't just train the front muscles for
flat abs you need to use exercises that
challenge you to brace your core one of
the best options for this is the hollow
body hold that you can also try plank
variations planche variations front
lever dragon flag LaLanne push-ups V ups
AB rollouts or uber vacuums
the other tip is to likewise train the
transverse plane a great midsection is
comprised of a six-pack but also defined
tube leaks on either side this gives you
that look of a shredded rippling
midsection rather than just a stuck on
set of abs combined with a low body fat
percentage it's a mean combo some great
options for this include harloff presses
medval throws heavy bag work cable punch
outs one-armed push-ups lizard crawls
and briefcase carries oh and when you do
train your rectus abdominis make sure
you're actually targeting the right area
many people will actually engage their
hip flexors rather than their abs when
doing sit-ups or crunches same with leg
raises
remember your abs are used to pull your
upper body towards your lower body focus
on crunching the core rolling it
forwards not folding at the waist I've
been doing a lot more of this kind of
training lately and that's played a big
role in giving me more defined abs
ultimately form follows function train
for performance and your looks will take
care of themselves something else I've
been doing a whole lot more up since
lockdown is walking seeing as my wife
and daughter weren't able to go to their
usual classes together during the day
we've been walking as a family in the
evenings which has been something really
nice to come out of all this walking is
a fantastic way of burning more calories
throughout the day in a very low
intensity manner and in fact if you want
to improve your general fitness one of
the best things you can do is to add
more extremely low intensity cardio to
your routine we're not supposed to be
either going full out all the time
or completely
we're supposed to be gently moving
constantly and this is something else
that I've been doing as well I made a
video recently a few months back about
splitting your workouts take a day and
incidental training so just finding ways
to get a small bursts of activity
throughout your day rather than just
relying on one big burst of exertion at
the gym for an hour or two hours and I
think this has also contributed a lot to
my general improvements in terms of
fitness and you know that more lean look
so it's something that I'm gonna keep
doing and I highly recommend to everyone
ultimately you shouldn't think of it as
training think of it as adaptation
change your environment and change your
routine and your body and your
performance will change in kind and
there you have it that's how I got more
ripped and that's what you need to do to
get more shredded abs hope you found
this useful and interesting let me know
how you train your midsection in the
comments down below and what you'd like
to hear about next give this video a
like and share it around if you enjoyed
it that helps me out immensely and of
course subscribe for much more like this
I've got lots more exciting stuff on the
way and if you want to learn more about
training for function first and
improving your general performance
you'll probably enjoy my ebook and
training programs super functional
training you can find a link to that in
the description down below and there's
discount on right now whilst we're all
in lockdown or some of us are anyways
thanks a ton for watching this one and
bye for now
so a few people had asked why I haven't
been doing these on camera talking
segments for a while okay one person
asked the reason I'm see was that my
hair was so awful that I just couldn't
do it but I'm coming back from the
hairdresser's now and I'm feeling a lot
more like myself so hi